[Music]
you know when you put a list together
you can come up with anything you want
based upon the factors that you use and
the formulas that you employ and there's
a professor at emory university that
came up with a ranking of all nfl fan
bases and i don't understand the
criteria i don't understand the formula
all i can tell is when i look at the
results
my 40 plus years of being an nfl fan and
following the sport and understanding
which teams are supported at home on the
road by their fan bases i look at this
list and chris
uh it's not good i'm being as tactful
and diplomatic as i can well what's this
good about it stinks i mean you're not
surprised the cowboys are number one i
would think with any formula they're one
but but how are the chargers at 26 where
is the chargers fan base who who goes to
chargers home games how are you fans of
the authority one the chiefs exactly
that's the one the loudest the loudest
venue in the world they're 31 well i
think it has too much to do with dollars
and social in the team social media
reaction which is not fair it's going to
favor big cities because of course yes
there's going to be more like wealth
there and and and maybe more people that
have a social reaction because it's a
big city
it's a made-up formula that is clearly
not reflective of how fans actually feel
about their teams i mean how are the
49ers number nine
watch a 49ers home game there's more
people on the field than there are in
the stands oh i know it's the sun they
all stay inside well they might be it's
a nice stadium i don't think you know
that they might be in the concourse
drinking pina coladas
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports